Speaker 1: Fox News was trigger early triggered
into being a sputtering mess by Joe Biden's
speech last night saying, hey, we should try
to maintain our democracy.
And Republicans running in November are running
now in 2022, are increasingly threatening
to upend it if they lose.
If I lose, it was rigged.
If I won, then it's fair.
Joe Biden with a very good speech, which we
already looked at.
Take a look at some of the reactions from
Republicans each.
I don't know whether to call these sad, whether
they call these dangerous, whether to call
them delusional.
Maybe it's a combination.
Let's look at them.
Here's Kevin McCarthy, the House minority
leader, reacting to Joe Biden's speech about
democracy being in danger.
That was the announced subject matter.
We knew the speech was going to be about democracy.
And Kevin McCarthy says, well, it was a bad
speech because he didn't mention inflation
or gas prices.
Speaker 3: I listened to the president's speech.
I don't remember hearing anything about inflation,
about gas, about border, about fitting off,
about crime or not.
Even the 98 individuals on the border who
are on the terrorist watch list they have
caught.
We're really finding in these next six days.
This is a hinge election.
This is this is a defining election, like
a 1980 election.
Which direction does America want to go?
That's why we have the commitment to America.
We literally spell out what we'll do.
Speaker 1: He's holding up a piece of paper
when he says.
Speaker 3: That because energy independent,
give us an economy that's strong.
Secure the border fund the police.
Stop the prosecutors who are woke.
Give you a parents bill of rights.
Speaker 1: Understand that all of those things
I mean, the economy, at least for now, is
fine.
We have almost full employment.
GDP growth is back.
Nothing has materially changed on the border
since Trump know all these things are completely
made up.
But the critique is he didn't talk about inflation
and gas prices.
The speech was about democracy because Kevin
McCarthy and the cronies in his party and
their constituents seem not to care about
democracy anymore.
That's why the subject matter was what it
was.
In reaction to Joe Biden's speech.
Jesse WATTERS, another beauty on Fox News
says This is all nonsense because we're just
going to win.
There's not going to be anything to deny.
Speaker 3: That was the president of United
States confessing that he's about to get wiped
out a week from now.
No one is going to question the results of
this election, Mr. President, because it's
going to be a blowout.
Speaker 1: Now, understand, Jesse thinks he's
being clever.
He thinks he's being clever by saying you're
not going to have any questioning because
we're going to win.
There's not going to be anything to question.
But he's actually proving exactly the point
that Joe Biden made, which is they don't question
it when they win and they question it when
they lose a priori by saying losses are fraud.
We'll talk later about what a priori means.
He seems to actually be proving Joe Biden's
point.
Now, is it true that the Democrats are going
to get wiped out?
Maybe.
We talked about new polling.
At the same time, there are growing concerns
that the new polling is very bad polling.
We're going to find out in, you know, what
is it, five days.
We'll know before you know it.
Just make sure you take your vote and use
it.
One other clip.
Here's Republican Senator Lindsey Graham also
talking about Joe Biden's speech and saying
he didn't even mention the border.
Well, no, it wasn't about the border.
Speaker 3: Stacey Abrams herself.
But that's not happening either.
What was your reaction to Biden's angry speech?
Speaker 1: By the way, it's logical to be
angry when one side doesn't care about democracy.
Speaker 3: If I'm a liberal Democrat, I would
say, Joe, please stop helping.
I thought it was pathetic.
I thought it was divisive.
Not one word about how I'm going to secure
a broken border, how I'm going to lower gas
prices as president, how I'm going to challenge
rampant crime, how I got the money.
Speaker 1: Is he already lowered gas prices
as president?
Speaker 3: This energy independent.
Speaker 1: It will if you believe the president
has anything to do with it, by the way, which
I don't.
But again, this is their story.
Speaker 3: It's about half the country basically
being political terrorist.
Speaker 1: Yeah, it's not half the country
that are political terrorists, but it's a
nonzero portion of the Republican Party.
And we're seeing it day to day.
These folks are pathetic.
These folks are pathetic and they are openly
subscribing to if we win.
It was fair.
And if we lose, it was rigged.
Let me know your thoughts in a comment or
find me on Twitter at D Pacman.
Remember, we are pushing to 2 million YouTube
subscribers, many of you out there.
Maybe I'm talking about you.
You watch our clips on YouTube, but you're
not subscribed.
Do us the favor of subscribing even if you're
seeing our videos in your feed because it
is the most important signal to YouTube's
algorithm.
Hey, maybe I should recommend this guy's content.
Remember that the David Pakman show is made
possible by our viewers, by our listeners.
That is the primary source of funding for
our show.
And I would love for you to sign up at joint
Pacman dot com where you will get instant
access to the commercial free audio and video
streams of the show as well as the bonus show.
Speaker 3: That is a frickin predator right
there.
Speaker 1: No, it's not predatory, Alex.
It's just it's just the bonus show through
Tuesday, through Election Day.
You can use the coupon code, big voting 22
to
secure a perfect discount.